подейкують Да що от 16 грудня президент
оголосить про президентські вибор Ну от
є така чутка те що вона ходить 16 грудня
цього року тому за оголосить та щоб
залишилося якраз три місяці там до
проведення їх Це просто є от там такі
сигнали які десьце я думаю що насправді
цього сьогодні в Україні не знає ніхто
чи будуть Президентські вибори навесні і
прямо буде залежати від позиції однієї
людини ми знаємо як її звуть цю людину
да це теж до реч говорить про те що Ми
багато чого упустили ми от всі ці рік і
с-8 місяців великої війни ми нічого не
внесли зміни про те як що би країна мала
робити для того щоб не підвішувати
легітимність виборчого процесу а могли б
зробити і сказати дуже чітко Да там чи
зміни в Конституцію чи наприклад ну до
речі Вони не вносяться під час воєнного
стану а принаймні там на рівні
законодавства якимось чином визначитися
із президентськими виборами також